formal education at least you know in  america for me i feel like formula  education failed most of us right you  know we we put a lot of money in there's  some in the u.s you can't bankrupt out  of the debt like you cannot get out of  the debt that you owe for your schooling  and the entire idea the original premise  of higher education was that you'd now  be a more valuable member to society to  be able to be more gainfully employed  and provide value right the problem is  that the promise is undelivered right  and people go in and get the same level  of income after they get a degree as as  what they could get before and if you  just look at the parallel track of  somebody who took the same amount of  money and spent it on what i would  consider alternative education over a  four year period  i would say almost invariably the person  who spends an alternative education  would be far better off four years later  than somebody who partied for four years  of college